[Music]
thank you and hello everybody and I'd
like to welcome the panelists onstage
please so if you'd come up this why
don't you sit here Wendy if you don't
feel that seat there David Mary oh okay
Wendy Lucy at the end yes we thought
we'd go for traditional dinner party
seating boy/girl girl/boy
only took us about an hour to figure
that out is it's so lovely to see this
wonderful big audience especially of
young faces um so let me first introduce
the panelists we have a lovely diverse
range of people Elizabeth Blackburn is
2009 Nobel laureate and physiology or
medicine of her her work on telomeres
and telomerase the enzyme that puts the
caps back on the ends of chromosomes
David gross is 2004 Nobel laureate in
physics his work discovering asymptotic
freedom in the strong nuclear force
there we have Wendy Taylor who is a
Rockefeller Foundation fellow and was
the founding director of USAID s Center
for accelerating innovation and impact
there we have Mario Molina 1995 Nobel
laureate in chemistry for his work
linking CFCs to the depletion of the
ozone layer and finally your own Lucie
Fortson who's professor of astrophysics
here and of course has deep experience
in promoting citizen science approaches
to challenges so please join me in
welcoming all our
so you already have gathered that we
have a very large range of expertise on
the panel and I'm looking forward to
exploring their different talent the
different challenges they've faced and
their different approaches to that to
those and to what they've learnt from
those approaches during the course of
the next hour and 15 minutes we'll also
take the chance to get questions and
comments from the audience at various
points during the discussion and we have
roving microphones for that we're here
to discuss how do we approach Grand
Challenges and we thought it might be a
nice way to start by thinking about what
we mean by the phrase Grand Challenges
and I suspect we have rather different
views on that so I'm going to ask the
panelists this would you start
what does Grand Challenges mean to you
well I think Provost Hansen challenged
us because she laid out in many ways
what we can think of this mini Grand
Challenges but I started thinking well
well what really brings all of those
together what is the really sort of
super grand challenge that is
encapsulated by the components that she
she outlined and and I'm starting to
think this is something that's risen out
of my research which lint lent itself
more and more to the question of how do
we as individuals and then more and more
societies how do we thrive and I so I
think really our grand challenge is
bringing to not just lucky us here but
the much greater world of people who are
often very impoverished very threatened
by what climate change will bring
getting the sort of lifting all of the
many parts of humanity up to the best
potential that people can have now that
sounds very vague but I think it's it's
that we've got such opportunities
technologically and scientifically to do
this and what we've lacked is something
that I'd call
a common long-term framework for
worldwide investment in how we bring
science to its best form we think
nationally I think we have to think much
more globally Paris Accords were a very
interesting example maybe we can take
off from that and say how do we use
science internationally how do we invest
in a long term and not just a short term
and regional and government way in what
can be brought to humanity by all of the
technological and scientific advances
that we have thank you what a wonderful
ambitious all-embracing vision of
challenges thank you David so given the
title of this panel was challenges I was
thinking about what are challenges it
seemed to me that we should distinguish
between at least between two or three
kinds of challenges one is an area like
global warming or the environment where
the science has been my opinion been
done and it's conclusive the challenge
is open and evident and the problem is
political but then there are challenges
that we're only beginning to realize are
coming and we can't even define them
very precisely and certainly although
science might provide some answers not
even clear what the question is for
example the information revolution
robotics and the the complete change
that that portends for the economy and
its effect on society or the incredible
advances in medicine and genetics and
which are going to affect society and
all of us in ways which I'm not I'm
certainly going to be challenging but
it's hard to enunciate
the challenges are in a sense those are
the most interesting challenges the
others are decided and clear we know how
to solve many of those challenges and
it's truly an issue of politics
economics money and power and then
finally there's the area in which many
of us work which is the most challenging
and the most exciting which are
scientific challenges and those are not
posed by us or by society but by nature
beautifully said thank you the challenge
of the unknown good ok Wendy I'm gonna
come to you lost for good reason Mary oh
please well briefly I'm biased in
answering this question about challenges
because I did participate must have been
almost a decade ago in what we thought
was the first Grand Challenge sort of
team which was organized by the National
Academy of Engineering in the u.s. I
remember we met in California and so on
above it was a very multidisciplinary
group and challenges is what what you
normally once you can think of for
example connected with climate change
and so on there is an engineering
challenge how do we make sure that we
can come up with ways to generate energy
with sustainable means so that we don't
harm the environment that's very much an
engineering challenge and there there
has been much advance there another
challenge what sort of question but
finally agreed to put it on the table
anyhow is how does the human brain work
ok what is the physics this chemistry
the biology the science and so these are
sort of engineering or scientific
challenges but then I thought of that
was no longer part of our job but some
of the big challenges that society has
are not just science or engineering
they are social and economic as well and
one I can simply put here as an example
we could discuss it in much more detail
is how do we improve education how do we
educate the masses because clearly many
of the difficulties that we have is
because we don't have the the citizens
at the level of the what we call a
democracy that we would like to have and
much has been learned about the
application we know much more
scientifically about how people learn
and so basically the technical and
scientific components are reasonably
well understood so the big challenge is
social how do we manage to make sure
that this new much better ways to learn
to teach and so on are actually
implemented because the sort of the
culture of teaching beginning in
elementary school high school and so
it's very difficult to change so I'm
just labeling the different components
and again to summarize I believe it's
more the social challenges that are the
ones that we should do something about
it
about them because they have huge
implications for the benefit of society
thank you very much indeed I'm beginning
to think that an hour and 15 minutes
isn't gonna be enough so I you know
couldn't agree more with the rest of the
panelists and so I think I'm going to
narrow in on a few things so I agree
with you Mario that educating the public
at some level that students of course
are part of the public that is one of
the big grand challenges and in
particular for an appreciation for an
understanding of the process of science
and you know there I even bring it up
but the whole issue of what fake news is
and and the ability to have judgment
that's built in through an education
process that gives each person
confidence that what they are
working with is close to the correct
answer so this can only come from really
you know understanding how to educate
but also providing the opportunities for
students and the public to engage in
problem solving themselves to gain that
confidence as they are working so how
can we do this at scale and so that's
one of my big challenges would be how do
we engage the public in the process and
understanding of a research and science
and then the other big challenge is
something that David alluded to which is
the artificial intelligence revolution
so what's the point of learning anything
if the machines are gonna do it all for
us anyways right so so I think one of
the big challenges is to make it clear
that there is a complementary
relationship between the artificial
intelligence that is being developed now
and the humans that will be taking
advantage of the artificial intelligence
so I think there's they're coupled in a
sense but they're two distinctly
different challenges how do we have
combined human and artificial
intelligence working in the best way
possible at the same time how do we
engage the public in scientific research
and understanding thank you very much
indeed
so already I think we've seen an
enormous d broad interpretation of Grand
Challenges and the mind expanding one
and there's an orphan there are many
threads to pick up on the reason I
wanted to come to Wendy last is there's
also a very specific way that the work
that were the Grand Challenges are used
of course and Wendy is particularly
concerned with that so how do you see
Grand Challenges well and I think this
is actually a great introduction to many
threads that we can pursue in this panel
but I think one way to distinguish a few
of the things I've heard is there's
there's both the what are the big grand
challenges that we need to solve and we
could come up with a really great list
since the University of Minnesota is
actually now taking on Grand Challenges
all of you can help solve them but but
also it's that how do we solve these
grand challenges and there's actually a
if there's it's so it's more of a the
method and one of the things that I've
worked on is is really using at Grand
Challenges as a tool to be able to solve
big problems and so we're hearing the
term Grand Challenges thrown around
quite a bit which is actually quite
exciting but it's it encompasses often
many different tools we can issue a
Grand Challenge competition that has
grant funding tied to it where you're
really trying to rally people to solve a
particular problem and and give out
awards to people with the best ideas
there are winner takes all prizes XPrize
has done these for a number of areas
there are ways to use crowdsourcing with
with different tools to solve challenges
so there's lots of different tools out
there but fundamentally the way I look
at it is Grand Challenges are about
empowering and incentivizing the global
community to solve some of humanity's
greatest challenges it's that there's
nothing more powerful than a big hairy
audacious goal to focus everyone's
energies and attention around solving
that and and that's really what Grand
Challenges are about it's it's how do
you elevate the focus of attention on a
well-defined problem and it needs to be
a well-defined problem how do you
catalyze and and inspire new solvers to
come at solving a problem and sometimes
it's actually bringing in people who
have never thought about the problem
before and have a new perspective that
they can bring to bear to a problem that
that comes up with completely new
solutions and then how do you generate
those ideas and those innovations those
solutions that that will ultimately
solve the problem and and so there are
these are tools that you can use it's an
approach that you can use and they've
been used we use them in the US
government when I was a part of the
Obama
ministration where we were encouraged to
use Grand Challenges to tackle big
problems we were we learned some of the
best grand challenges that you want
audacious but achievable goals you want
well-defined problems you want to be
able to inspire new solvers to come to
the table so we used them everywhere
from finding ways to save the lives of
mothers and newborns around the time of
birth and the hardest to reach parts of
the world Department of Energy is trying
to figure out how to get solar as cheap
as coal by the end of the century NASA
is trying to figure out how to save the
planet from asteroids all of these have
used Grand Challenges to tack tackle
these big problems and the one last
thing I would say is I think one of the
things I find really exciting about a
Grand Challenge if you put it out there
it can act as a magnet it can be a
magnet for new resources coming to the
problem it can be a magnet for people
power and and brainpower and and a
magnet for new ideas and and that's
that's kind of the secret sauce of where
we can use these tools to be able to
solve some of these big challenges that
you've already heard some of today I
mean it's an enormous ly attractive idea
is with the increased number of grand
challenges that are out there is there a
danger of kind of Grand Challenge 40
what do you think sure and I mean I work
in an area where where funding is scarce
and I've you know I've gone around
looking under couch cushions for for
enough money to scrape together to put
together challenge so funding is is one
problem but we have a lot of solvers out
there I mean one of the things that is
is great about these challenges is you
can put them out there and different
challenges appeal to different people so
we put them out there and you're
appealing to engineers and entrepreneurs
and scientists and students and citizen
scientists and and different challenges
can appeal to different people so I
think if you find the right way to
engage the right communities it's it's
really limitless right yeah this we
wanted to come in
question of fatigue yes I mean maybe the
grand challenge is to you know define
more grand challenges because you know
we don't want to have that fatigue
situation because everybody's and
clearly it's a successful term because
because it's been embraced so broadly
you know all sorts of foundations as you
said government entities so you know the
question is you know I keep sort of
stepping back instead of saying well
really what is the really huge
challenges here and maybe we're just
dancing around them by these very
specific parts are you know is humanity
really as good as it could be you know
we keep saying you know humanity is just
terrific
I'm sorry humanity has kind of a bad
history I'm really sorry to say this but
you know you might have noticed you know
Syria I mean you know a few little
details like this so I think this idea
that maybe our human potential hasn't
really been reached properly and maybe
machines are good I wear glasses you
know I'd be I'd be you know eaten by a
saber-toothed tiger if I were in the old
world with my eyesight terrible eyesight
so I'm now able to you know reach my
potential as a human because I can see
things now we have fantastic
technologies connectivity
maybe we can sort of aspire to you know
thinking about well what what does
humanity really really aspire to because
you know we do lots of activities but
some of them are rather you know
unfortunate in their in their outcomes
[Music]
not being very specific can we perfect
humanity's a challenge as by you know
the Buddha Jesus about asking questions
good questions is is very important for
sure that however when you pose Grand
Challenges which is sort of a way of
marshaling resources and getting
additional money nowadays
United say you better be slightly
general otherwise you'll be asking the
wrong question and forcing researchers
or thinkers or doers to work in US
Pacific direction that you've defined
before you know how things really should
go but but it's always good to have some
challenges last for centuries
mathematicians are very good at this
they established challenges Hilbert
established 120 years ago a list of
challenges which people have still not
completely answered and it that but
Hilbert was Herbert I mean he had to had
to correctly come up with very specific
questions that could survive 120 years
most of the challenges that are that
come up at least in the scientific area
of ways of getting extra money in an era
of declining resources are haven't
necessarily worked out so if you look
back at them they've either produced
resources that have been used for
different questions than were imagined
originally or veered off I'm gonna let
Wendy reply to him and then I'm gonna
come to you Mary yeah I just I wanted to
make one response to the point you made
at the beginning about how broad or how
narrow you define these challenges and
end with the Grand Challenge model that
we've used we actually we talked about
it as the the Goldilocks problem where
it and this is really more art than
science but but you if you defy it how
you define the problem makes all the
difference in terms of the kinds of
solutions that you get and so if you
define it too broadly you get a mess and
you end up sort of not really figuring
out is that the ones who are making the
choices of what to fund you get a mess
of ideas and they're just very unfocused
and and and they may not even hit the
mark and if you go too narrow then you
constrain creativity you creams drain
people's thinking
they might not think beyond the margins
and in new ways and that's actually that
space where you might find the solutions
so so there is kind of an art to
thinking about how you get these new
ideas to come in so the challenge is
posing the challenge they're not being
occupied with it having a pre-determined
answer which is what I think David was
saying I'm having the National
Institutes of Health extramural funding
you know very nationwide very broad one
of the the leaders of that program once
said we give money to you know
scientists researchers and we say to
them take the money and run and I
thought that was really to put more
explicitly another complication with the
challenges which we've all brought up to
some extent which is the funding okay
but I'm thinking of space exploration
for example or the big colliders and so
on so when we're talking about very
large investments but for example with
space exploration there is the question
is there life somewhere else okay so
that's a very big question but it's it's
sort of goes beyond pure science it's
more a matter of we as humans are really
only ones here and what have you so this
is this sort of moves more into the
philosophy philosophical parts of that
but I think it's a point we cannot
ignore because how do we allocate
resources and again for high energy
physics some of the experiments are very
expensive what you're trying to find out
how matter works it will pay off okay
but I also mentioned that because it's
one of the challenge with politicians
okay see where are you giving me back
for the money I'm giving you and I think
that's often very short-sighted so a
challenge is to
particularly when we're talking about
the current administration it's to
really continue to doing basic science
which is fundamental for the progress of
of humanity that's something we can talk
about for a long time but it it's
obvious for historical reasons that we
should really keep spending with keep
using resources to pursue fundamental
science I'm gonna come back to you in a
second Mary oh but um Lucy yes please
yes so I think you touched on a few very
key things there and and one of them is
what the public thinks of as a grand
challenge is not necessarily what we
would think of as Grand Challenges so
you could be crass and say well it's our
job to figure out how to sell the grand
challenge to the public so that they're
along for the ride to the moon when we
all know that the reason we went to the
moon is was not necessarily a grand
challenge in that sense it was a grand
political challenge so so you know so
bringing the public alone for the right
well so an a couple of people already
mentioned this as well you have to
motivate the the public you have to get
them engaged and you and you know I
think I've already said this and Laura
you said this it's something it's about
the education it's about giving them the
tools that they can then use over a life
long time of learning
so that they they can help us define
what the Grand Challenges are they can
participate in some of the USA Grand
Challenges they can even participate in
some of Hilbert's challenges that some
of those mathematical challenges are
being crowd-sourced as well I'm not sure
they've come to any true successful
conclusions but the idea is there and it
can be motivating for a student who
particularly is interested in in
mathematics there's now this opportunity
to work with other like-minded people
through the connectivity of the of the
web to try to solve some of these larger
Grand Challenges so for us it's how do
we engage the public for lifelong
learning and give them the tools so that
they
approach the Grand Challenges in
whichever way is best for suited for
them instead of sitting back and
watching the next television show or
reading tweets or whatever or
facebooking the tools and it's also
democratizing access to opportunities
yes exactly right
Mario you you're you're quite rare in
that you took a very basic scientific
observation and then followed that
through to a global policy change the
banning of CFCs how did you and your
colleagues and everybody involved engage
people to believe in what was going on
because when you started it was not I
mean it was just science there was
unknown everybody yes well we had to
make a decision sherry Rowland that and
I sort of remember discussing that it at
that time this was last century decades
ago it was really not customary for
scientists to go out and to try to
convince the public that something had
to be done it was sort of not very well
regarded because if publish in the New
York Times instead of in science or
nature you're not a very good scientist
the perspective but we realized at that
time things have changed a little bit if
it is not us sherry and I then who and
if it's not now when
and we decide we need to go out and so
we had to learn how to communicate to
the public and of course we realize it
was important first to try to
communicate with the session makers in
government with politicians and we had
some success doing that and also with
the press what we had to learn how do
you have a press release and so on and
it took some time okay
at the beginning we were communicating
very well with other
scientists we managed to get the
National Academies to look into the
problem and eventually write a report so
slowly things began to move but I think
we were quite successful even though we
had to convince the public in general we
were quite successful with decision
makers at very high levels in government
with diplomacy and so on and that sort
of was one way to better communicate
with the public it's sort of a two-way
thing that you have to do both at the
same time but eventually we thirdly we
managed but we had to be very patient
thank you David sir so this is our what
this is a great success story but the
most amazing in fact but it's it really
it stands out for another reason is that
it's almost unique so after the war
Second World War physics committee took
on itself to deal with the danger of
nuclear weapons and that was generation
of my teachers but they were pretty good
at it and they finally got around to
some kind of arms control and
non-proliferation but we have to keep up
that's not a great success story we
still have 20,000 nuclear weapons aimed
each other we could still wipe out the
whole planet all life on the planet in
less than 24 hours you know and and in
fact the US and Russia the two major
superpowers are in the process of
planning to build better and more usable
and more expensive and more and more
nuclear weapons right now and
most of this room probably doesn't know
feel in the same way that my generation
did about the danger of nuclear
annihilation because it's we've had a
pretty peaceful earth for the last at
least nuclear wise for the last 30 40 70
years but the danger is there enormous
and and Silas stop you know we don't
talk about it too much anymore danger is
actually much worse today than it was 30
years ago and people are unaware of this
so this is not a question of science
neither was the discovers in the
atmospheric chemistry that was settled
it then became a political issue but
some political issues don't haven't yet
been solved and they are truly dangerous
and threatening to all of us so Marie
Curie said nothing in life is to be
feared as it's only to be understood now
I think she was not quite right in that
what you just said is very much to be
feared but my feeling is a scientist is
I want to understand what is it about
this amazing brain of ours that
collectively does such bizarre things
that we end up with what was it 20
thousand each pointed at each other that
is really strange and you know maybe
that life what did they find seven more
planets that had earth-like qualities
just just for seven together yes that's
right they're probably looking at us
thinking what are we thinking
unfortunately the best answer to where
they are is that they blew them so
lessons to be learned so maybe we have
to you know I mean I'm being a little
frivolous but you know you're saying
earth might be doomed there's been this
science fiction scenario forever you
know how do we get off earth and this is
a very grand challenge because we but we
might need to think about it because our
planet is getting pretty maxed out
environmentally and only going to be you
know most arable land is
under under agriculture right now
agriculture is being very threatened by
climate change as will you know large
populations yeah you know we all know
the the danger so this planet is in not
great shape and so every effort it seems
should be to pull it back until we can
you know use the physics and get back to
earth I'm going to bring it locally so
both of you
you know posed global issues scary
global issues in your case thank you so
much for doing what you did to to help
preserve the the atmosphere okay so I'm
not going to touch that one but the you
know the risk of climbing up on my
soapbox again I'm gonna say there is
another example which is the Flint
Michigan water crisis which was it so
well yeah yes and and it was solved with
a lot of help by citizen scientists who
were who took matters into their own
hands and so this is where there is hope
when we have the the public for their
own reasons and and you know this is
definitely a motivational force when
they start seeing water that is oozing
out Brown in their bathtubs and and
whatnot and being told by the City
Council that oh no don't worry it's
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
the way it is it's said I mean there's a
whole story to it you can google the
Flint Michigan water crisis if you don't
know about it but bottom line is there's
a mother who was desperately worried
about her children great motivating
force there and she took it upon herself
to learn how to do water quality tests
she got the equipment to do that
she got enough equipment to train her
neighbors and they were able to put
together enough data in the first
instance when they went to the City
Council they were not able to convince
the City Council why as it turns out for
reasons which that's just there were
politics involved let's leave that aside
but they were they pursued they
persevered and they were actually able
to convince the state that there was an
issue with the water quality and it was
damaging their health and at the end of
the day they were actually able to make
policy change so the point being that if
you start local to things that matter to
people at you know we are human and
we're tribal in some sense right so we
we care about things that are local so
this goes back to my point about
rephrasing how do we phrase the Grand
Challenges so that the people at the
local scales in the small towns or in
you know places in the world where they
don't care about Google they care about
eating and finding you know shelter not
finding a way to survive how how can we
translate all of the tools and what not
give them the power empower them to make
change policy change understand the
science etc at the very local scale and
then that will bubble up and hopefully
give us the ability to make changes
before it's too late
on the larger global scales but I think
you know it's you raise a great point
and it's something that we thought a lot
about when we were running our Grand
Challenges and we're working in the
global development space and and are
keenly aware of a lot of failed efforts
of people sitting in ivory towers or
somewhere in some Silicon Valley office
on the west coast trying to solve
problems for people in communities
halfway across the world that they
really didn't understand so there is
really value in trying to empower people
who are closest to a problem to find
ways
to solve it but it's also about creating
sort of a platform in an outlet for them
to solve it and and so we often talk a
lot and the Grand Challenges one of our
big learnings was that good ideas can
come from anyone and anywhere and two of
my favorite examples of that came out of
our saving lives at birth Grand
Challenge where one of our innovators he
was an Argentinean car mechanic with no
more than a high school education who
came up with the first innovation for
obstructed labor in half a century and
he was inspired by actually watching a
YouTube video about how to get a cork
out of a wine bottle you push the cork
all the way in and it's a great party
trick so you can look it up but he saw
this and while in the shop with his
buddies during the day and in the middle
of night he woke up and had this aha
moment and he shakes his wife and he
looks at her and he says I figured out a
solution for obstructed labor and she
thought he was crazy but here this this
very smart mechanic actually prototyped
in his kitchen with a jar and his
daughter's baby doll and went to an OB
and and got some good user feedback that
he was on to something and eventually we
actually found it and and Becton
Dickinson is now developing this advice
and is going to bring it to the
developing world and another quick
example is a Rice University engineering
student senior year developed a
prototype for a bubble CPAP and bubble
CPAP is for acute respiratory distress
which is actually one of leading causes
of newborn mortality and and you will
you can go to any hospital here in the
Twin Cities and find bubble CPAP sand
the knee cues they cost $4,000 so she
figured out she got a plastic shoebox
from Target now gene bottles that you
might find in a fish tank and she
developed a prototype that actually
worked and they they of course refined
that prototype with some better
materials and brought the cost from
4,000
$400 got it working world-class
standards and it has three times the
survival rate for newborns and it's now
getting deployed throughout throughout
Africa so that there are there are
problems that can be solved that perhaps
are not so big as figuring out where we
come from and whether there's life on
other planets
but that have really big meaningful
impact on people's lives today and these
and if we find ways to engage people to
solve these problems we can have
tremendous impacts how did you engage
that mechanic and Argentina well so part
of it was we when we issued our grand
challenge we had a number of partners we
had the Gates Foundation we had Canada a
number of other countries involved with
us so we had a pretty and us eight has a
pretty big platform so we pretty much
announced to the world that we were
looking for new solutions and and and
you've got a lot of attention our first
year and and by that point that
innovation had already sort of it was
already getting prototyped and it made
its way into some circles in the
development community so so we found we
found him but but part of the key is is
how do you actually put these out there
in a way that sort of open it up to new
communities and and you have to think
about how are you incentivizing the
kinds of people that might be able to
come to the table and solve a problem
and how do you reach them how are you
using you know we've all heard about the
abuses of you know shared information
and so on and I think that's the real
challenge it's such a good potential
technology and yet we've seen it go down
these routes that you know and yet
there's examples you're giving where it
you know how does one devise the
technology in such a way that's you know
the worst part so that you know become
minimized cuz that would be a very
practical kind of yes but yet I wanted
just to give a it's a bit of a counter
example just to point out that there are
different ways in which you can look at
great challenges
it's just climate change because you
could be very pessimistic as
look how the hell are you are you going
to convince people in a small town to
worry about this problem they can do
practically nothing about it because
it's a global problem what you have to
be optimistic of course we can certainly
solve it we know how to the sciences
we'll establish and the technology the
technologies are out there already so
what's a challenge just politics and so
you need the support of the people they
have to understand it they have to
support their leaders Luce is talking
about scientific politics ok but that's
politics and that's where you talk about
your children I want my children to do
well otherwise why the hell do we have
primary schools or second or even
universities the investment is not going
to show up for decades ok no but people
worry about their children but if you
can involve all those those people as I
keep saying locally they it's not that
the you know holy scientists have come
up with a big solution and then they're
going to be the recipients of this
amazing solution that is I would suggest
not the way to approach it that they
approach is to get them for example to
crowdsource the data locally for example
for Siberian fishermen to provide notes
on the whaling or the fish populations
or some way of getting information from
these indigenous peoples or you know
people that are literally the ground
truth that can then filter up into large
databases that then write but a very
important point just do that do it
certainly you have to show them and I
agreed but that's what the specific zone
climate is changing around them and
sometimes for the better what often but
in in many other cases it's getting dry
or whatever but that's why they have to
understand that we're talking about some
social responsibility for the future
what we have the solution we don't have
to do any sacrifices it's not that you
have to give up something so that my
children can do better
we just have to change the way we do
things and if you do it with creativity
you can increase the number of jobs you
can improve the economy so you have to
convince everybody but using to the
extent that you can some of the local
effects but it's it's a big challenge
that's what I call a grand challenge
because it's clear that we all have to
do it together the entire world for at
least the heads of state so the charr
entirely in agreement with one exception
unfortunately all the heads of state
accept the challenge is to try and
understand why we work apparently so
much in against our own you know
interests as ignorant or
irresponsibility I think it's that
amazing complex thing our brain and this
amazing interconnectedness has and what
how we end up you know I think
understanding how this functions would
be very helpful because we see it at
work in it's so many earners you know
not there are conflicting interests
there are yet and yet the world has done
amazing amounts of cooperative things
and you know people who've sort of tried
to quantify you know I think it was
Steven Pinker right you know we're
better at not killing each other
worldwide and and and so although I
think that was slightly out of date but
no I but he did do a very interesting
analysis historically and concluded
humanity actually you know has shown
more signs of cooperation so I think
there's a lot of possibilities because
we have the technologies there but we
have to understand you know how people
really work and not just how we would
like them to work because that was our
upbringing that gave us a a pre you know
frequency view of how things work I
think we really have to do the true hard
basic science to understand what makes
this extraordinary you know species
humans it would be nice that if in
addition to biology chemistry physics we
had real sciences in the fields that
attached science to their
political science spoken like that but
maybe they turn around clicks you see
mom she couldn't have been the science
but it was vitalism it was big we didn't
have tools you know so to quote John
Nash was once asked he just won a
memorial nobel prize in economics
science and he was asked by a reporter
his economics and science and he said
any field that needs to add to its title
the word science isn't this why it's
physics but biological sciences biology
there we go I'm gonna go to the audience
in one second but you mentioned you
matched the word incentives and it's
quite often prizes output as for those
who can solve a grand challenge is that
a good idea is it good to have people
unite around a prize yeah I think prizes
are another tool in the toolbox if you
will and and so you have to know when to
use them it's this when do you use what
kind of tool and prizes can actually
work very well they've historic there's
some great examples historically I did
what some of the lore around prizes is
you have to think about it's the guts
gold glory and I'm gonna forget the
other G there's four G's Gophers genius
[Laughter]
but but so it's a part of it is is so
you have different reasons why people
might step up to a prize so so Charles
Lindbergh responded to the Orteig prize
which I think was in 1919 which is a for
the first transatlantic flight and I
think there was a $25,000 reward and and
maybe that decent money back then but
I'm not
huge purse but there were certainly guts
involved a lot of people had died and
there was a lot of glory and and so so
it but it did serve to get people to to
solve that prize a prize XPrize the
ansari prize has was quite successful
i've so there are it's another tool to
sort of catalyze people to solve a
problem and and and good sorry i forget
good as the other g but so you can you
can decide to step up to a prize for for
a number of reasons and and and glory
sometimes is is part of the the big
thing if there is a big prize out there
you can some people might want the the
glory that comes comes with it a you
gonna respect could guess that with the
question of basic science i think what
you're saying works very well when
there's a defined a more defined goal
but basic science i don't know anybody
in basic sciences who said well okay i'm
gonna start this hard career because I
want to get a Nobel Prize everybody I
know did it because they were just
motivated by the extraordinary you know
journey and the curiosity and the
satisfaction of doing what you do right
so so I think what you're saying is it's
it's a toolbox thing but I think we
shouldn't mistake it for the really long
term investment in basic and
foundational research that we really
have to make sure is not lost and I
think I mean I we keep hearing basic
science come up and I think absolutely
no one should walk away saying that this
this is an alternative to making really
robust investments in basic science this
is really almost when you're further
down the line you're benefiting from
that knowledge yes and you actually have
the potential to leverage all of these
insights and be able to sell probably
Lucy there's there's another thing that
we've learned so I
co-founded a crowdsourcing platform
called suniverse that organ and we we
have you know nearly 1.7 million people
worldwide that contribute to our
projects and so we have I failed the
tutorial we were having discussions
about this before but yes depends on the
project and the incentive structure
going to yes so so we have found that
the incentive that people they actually
want to participate in research it isn't
having to do with an e come competitive
aspect so in our first project we
actually had leaderboards because we
figured of course you know we're kind of
gamifying things here and so we want to
have the people who classified the most
galaxies be able to show up and that'll
incentivize people we were dead wrong so
it turns out that the people who
actually want to contribute to our
projects are actually turned off by
competition we have found we have done
research on that so understanding the
complexities of the human brain they
feel they want to actually be part of a
larger whole and contribute and and when
they are pressured into competition they
actually remove themselves from the site
so we find there there there are
definitely different incentive
structures and so people do things for
and it said that you know people look at
things like purpose in life and it's
often identified with getting involved
in something that's bigger than just to
you so that plays into very much that
you know as I understand social research
and psychological research points to
people really having this you know this
desire to to contribute this yeah yeah
so it's a marvelous venue in which to be
able to contribute
perfect introduction is desire to
contribute who would like to ask a
question please here have you ever liked
phone here please
hi I'm Neha I'm an undergraduate here
studying chemistry and physiology and
you guys have discussed a lot about you
know I kind of see these grand
challenges framed in two ways like basic
sciences like chemistry physics
physiology all these things but then
there's also global challenges that I
think we are too privileged to recognize
and something that you mentioned is a
big part of solving that is empowering
these people so I've noticed like in in
the United States we do a lot to fund
basic sciences there's the NIH there's
Ennis ma NASA so do you think we should
be putting more resources towards these
other global issues and empowering these
people so they can help their own
population so a great example that comes
to mind is climate change
we don't really recognize it as a
problem because our country the weather
is great for the most part we can
accommodate it there's air conditioning
but I went to India in the summer last
year and the temperature where my
grandmother lives has increased by
almost 20 degrees in the past 30 years
what she said so it's kind of it's kind
of a weird question I'm asking but how
do you think we should address this
issue of allocating funds and resources
like where should be focusing what's the
priority is there actually air
conditioning is spreading like mad in
India but it's complicated if you have
air conditioning uses energy resources
so to run the air conditioners for the
400 million middle-class of India
requires a lot of coal burning which
pollutes the environment in a way that
are you know it's really unimaginable
these things are all tied together and
this is what government and informed
government is about and politics is
about these priorities you know the
pendulum whose priorities the people who
are living with the consequences of
pollution of the of a atmosphere in New
Delhi or you know the middle class in
New Delhi which lives in a big apartment
building and once they have a cool
summer there's no answer I know that
comes from scientists is a political
social decision I think just a
complementary answer is that there's one
clear set of investments that economists
working together with engineers in
connection with climate change they
agree upon it's a very good investment
to keep doing research on the
technologies that need to be improved
and so on because it will pay off it's
very good for the economy it's like an
investment and clearly we have examples
wind energy solar energy and so on came
out of the more fundamental more basic
research what we have now very applied
questions like how do you store this
energy and so that's a good investment
but I I would contrast that with the
other issues we were talking about basic
science why should you invest in basic
science if it's doesn't pay off of
course it pays off we know historically
that having investments in basic
sciences and having incentives for
industry like we have here with 3m and
so on so that they can actually get the
benefits of doing research if you put
all that together then it makes a lot of
sense just historically from an economic
perspective to invest both in basic and
and in applied technologies and there I
want to bring up again that one very
important investment in very basic
science in universities is so that you
can have very good
teachers and so education is for the
benefit of humanity and we know that
basic science and so on is best thought
when you have students actually doing
research themselves with research units
it doesn't have to be expensive Applied
Research things so yes there's a big
question how do you allocate resources
but I think we have enough experience so
it can done very cleverly there's a
support for basic science in this
country is very small even though it
sounds expensive nothing compared to
what we were what we spend on on
important things like the military and
and getting smaller and I would say that
the amount of money that we put into
development assistance is smaller even
than was what is going into the basic
science so lesson 1 percent of the
federal budget goes into supporting
development programs which is a lot less
than I think people think about and I
would argue as a development person that
we absolutely have a responsibility to
be addressing challenges that people are
facing all over the world and sometimes
when we're making the advocacy argument
for it we have to actually bring it back
home and help people figure out why they
should care I work in health and so so
we can think about it in multiple ways
the health of our planet is inextricably
linked to the health of humans and there
are really great opportunities to be
able to be addressing both diseases
infectious diseases know no boundaries
they certainly know no walls and can get
over walls and so so so we and we saw
this with Ebola as how suddenly a
problem that was in West Africa suddenly
became a global problem that everybody
was acutely aware of and so so I would
say absolutely we need to be investing
and and we need to be focusing attention
and we need to be able to empower people
whether they're sitting in the
University of Minnesota
or whether they're sitting in and Delhi
and other places where they could
actually be figuring out how to solve
some of the challenges they're facing
it's not just can I just go a little bit
beyond the diseases because when you
talked about acute diseases they catch
our attention but in fact the really big
global burdens and I'm talking all
across the world much more long-term
ones you know prominently you know
depression is becoming a huge one in
certain parts of the world and not just
the well developed you know societies
economically but I think that you know
the investment in trying to prevent
diseases like these huge global burdens
not only reacting to Ebola and dramas
that you know tracking our attention but
anticipating the longer-term
trajectories of the very major global
burdens of you know we look at cancers
and cardiovascular and diabetes and
Alzheimer's and these are things that
take years it's going to take real
investment and it'll be a really really
good use of money Mary Lasker who found
it you know was very much a proponent of
research and biomedical science she said
this wonderful thing which was you think
research is expensive try disease right
and but I think it's the really
long-term ones that we don't understand
all the unfolding steps yet but getting
much closer and understanding the
earlier and earlier etiology of these
diseases so I think you know it's not
just self-interest it seems very clear
that this is it's not just an indulgence
it's a really really important
underpinning to invest in this way thank
you question I know and then here please
hello in light of you talking about
democratizing access to information and
trying to get everyone involved I was
wondering what problems you see with the
publishing industry and where you see
the future of that going and what we
need to fix with it in order to get
everywhere involved and try to optimize
humanity so are you thinking
specifically of science publishing here
or the Internet
or anything in general that's pretty
it's a big new challenge to consider
okay who wants to take on the publishing
are there any editors in the room I mean
I could I can give it a go right so I
mean so one other things so you know we
run this crowdsourcing platform and one
of the things that we require and we've
run into with publishers that publish
the results of our work we require that
the publication be open source because
we have 1.7 million volunteers they have
contributed their time and effort it's
not fair to put the publication's
that benefited from their effort behind
a paywall
so we've worked successfully with
several publications so that they will
they give us they give us an out and so
any research team that works with our
platform for these particular
publications will want to publish in
those particular publications they
they're allowed to be free because of
the work that we do you know I have no
idea how you can solve that problem and
in large scale I'm gonna toss that over
to somebody else
mario's well the point I want to make
connection with that I think it's an
important one that to recognize that we
in the scientific community have done a
fairly poor job in communicating with
the public that goes all for basic
science as well as for applied science
like climate change because part of our
culture was just to communicate among
ourselves even just in our discipline
fortunately that's changing I come back
to education we can do much better that
way
but what we are missing is to really
learn how to communicate to the public
first applied problems like climate
change we need professional
communicators we're doing that but we
these need to work much more actively to
make sure that this this is properly
explained but it would be very nice to
also have for some of the very exciting
basic science ideas to be more broadly
communicated and we don't have enough
sort of US scientists in in the public
media you might a Buddhist had ways to
make it interesting I think we could do
a much better job so I'm hoping that
some one of the issues that will improve
a lot with better education we need more
neil degrasse tyson's right there is a
real crisis in newspaper magazine print
publication which has affected science
reporting widely most of venues have
gone out of business
very few newspapers have science
journalists anymore
the talent of science writers is out
there actually and there are some new
initiatives examples of what I'll give
an advertisement of a wonderful online
totally free subsidized by the Simons
Foundation magazine called quanta which
is superb you can sign up quanta quanta
quanta Google you can sign up and get a
article a day brilliantly Illustrated
wonderful science reporting we need to
do more of that
to replace the Scientific Americans and
other magazines that are really losing
ground to online stuff which isn't so
good that you see and that can I think
should be and the Nobel Foundation
actually is one of the great you know
you go to their website and you'll find
incredible amount of information not
just about the Prize winners and their
science but the associated it's a
wonderful resource there lots of things
like that available online but but I
want to pick up on that and go back to
your original question in the sense of
democratizing you know access to
research at even the highest levels what
you say is absolutely correct David but
again you know we see when there are the
published papers available to the people
that work on our
our projects they will look up they will
go into the literature and they will
familiarize themselves with the topic
that they're working with be it plankton
or penguins or galaxies or what-have-you
and and they will discuss amongst
themselves on our discussion boards but
if they did not have the access to those
publications they would not be able to
have those exchanges and so I think the
root of your question is we can't just
hide nothing hide but but we can't just
rely on the ability to quote translate
the science the real work the real
science the real publications have to be
available to the public to be able to do
publish with Lucy excuse me who do you
bother who publishes your fine
so they Monthly Notices of the Royal
Astronomical Society we have who's the
publisher Oh mm Oxford yes so but the
physics community is better than most in
making is it stuff available but there
is I there is something I suppose rather
strange about all talking about wanting
to engage the public in science and yet
working behind these file exactly yeah
but just a brief note we also have to do
much better with what we call the social
networks because you're right the normal
way to communicate things with magazines
or even if it's out there in the web
doesn't world that much the new
generations are sort of accustomed to
doing relatively short things so we need
to be maybe give another example that
came out of the Ebola experience where
where there were a lot of researchers
who wanted to get access to the data
even when they got access to the data
there were a challenge you know some of
them once they did their analysis they
actually held that information and
waited because they were waiting to be
able to publish and those timelines
don't really
work very well when you're in the middle
of an outbreak in a crisis and and that
was a great case where you can imagine
some kind of crowdsourcing open
innovation platform where people are
putting out what they're learning as
they're learning in real time and
researchers are then sort of building
off each other's knowledge so you can
actually figure out how to solve a
problem quickly and and that was an
example of where some of the publishing
rules got in the way and and there's
certainly been interesting conversations
in the how to address well I remember
when there was a stem-cell controversy
and somebody had made a very extravagant
claim and people just immediately went
to their labs tried to reproduce it
about ten different labs tried put down
exactly what they had found which was it
didn't work and within something like a
couple weeks the whole thing had gone
away and saved an enormous amount of
wastage of time so so when science does
bypass the older publishing models that
can be very good I was just going to add
though in the cancer research arena the
medical you know vast amounts of data
about people's you know detailed
molecular characteristics and DNA and
epigenetics of their cancers and there's
a big movement now to try to get the
world communities of cancer researchers
to not do what you're saying hang onto
their data but to share it and Joe Biden
with whom you know starting with the
moonshot but now very actively in the
cancer the Biden cancer initiative is
getting people to try to realize that
that's a standard that everybody gains
from in the end
first of all standardization and then
ignore me but what was that what what
always happens is happening things are
really cutting up and we're running out
of time
I promised that I promised someone over
there he'd get a question he will but
does anybody want to pick up on this
precise point of publication okay let me
just take your question in the front
please we have a microphone here quick
and then and then I will come to you I
promise and I know there's a forest of
hands over here we'll see what we can do
let's keep at it let's move rapidly fast
answers first
oh here we go
I'll be quick but this is in defense of
science writers cos s3 actually our
science writer and part of the problem
is is you know what we're doing is we
have to understand communication and how
people consume that communication but
when we take those concepts to
scientists they're not often they don't
want their information to be portrayed
in the ways that we are trying to get
that consumed by the public cuz your
goal is the same as our goal to get that
out to people so I guess I don't have a
question except our just a comment that
I think science and science
organizations have to be a little more
open to working with the media to allow
us to help you get that information out
there in a way that will hopefully go
viral you know and get out to the public
through I would have praised science
right as I've worked with who I thought
have been really good the problem is
often been with the headline writers and
that accounts for some scientists
reluctance the article will be great to
to credit to your profession what yes
yes quick mate so you're actually really
think and that and that can distort the
science in ways that make scientists
more reluctant so that's a very
interesting problem to solve it's
probably a grand challenge it's an
important one it yeah hello my name is
Raymond so we talked a lot today about
governments and individuals
my interest is mainly in corporations
and here at Minnesota we are we have
home of many large corporations
including United Health Group insuring
over 50 percent of domestic population
cargo which has over 14 percent of the
global like food supply in their supply
chain and a lot of students here are
going to be employed by those
corporations or house we as individuals
can take on these grand challenges while
we're still working participate in
Zooniverse projects okay Wendy yeah
remember brief yeah I would just say I
think there's lots of ways for
corporations to engage you're engaging
and solving challenges even just within
you know part of your core mission
companies can work as part of corporate
social responsibility and and put out a
challenge Qualcomm put out the tricorder
the XPrize so yes think star trek of a
trike a little device that could
actually detect all kinds of diseases
diagnosed all kinds of diseases
you've got Elon Musk
with SpaceX who is saying he he wants to
die on Mars but doesn't want to die on
impact but he's actually looking to try
to make sure we have sort of where a
multi-planet species but there's lots of
companies can there's ways to take on
some of these big challenges and and the
more the actually companies do it where
it's part of their business interest
rather than just a corporate social
responsibility the more engaged they'll
be and so we've we always look for that
angle okay maybe you as students can be
demanding of your employers when you are
job interviewing and you have a choice
of companies you could ask well what's
your company's policy in this if you
want to hire me maybe I would be more
motivated to go to a company you know
I'm a student here who's graduated has
job offers you might be motivated to a
company that is thinking yeah okay
please all right firstly I'd like to
thank you all for taking the time to
come out and I'm sure you're all
tremendously busy but I think this may
be a good question to finish on unless
we have time for more but and piggy
backing out that last one just what do
you think are the most pressing problems
that individuals could work on today and
I guess more specifically if you were to
put yourself in students shoes and all
these students in the audience where do
you think your time could be most well
spent
whether that's issues that have the
least amount of support and that require
help or maybe are the most pressing
issues that have a lot of support but
still require help as well nice question
okay quick round you each get a couple
of sentences on this
content may not be so important as
really high quality and creativity of
the research because you never know what
it's going to be influencing basic
scientists speaking if you're asking it
for real advice I would have to
interview you first what do you decide
to work on really they should depend on
your passions and your abilities and
your interests and you know there's so
many great challenges in so many
different areas that I'm sure after a
brief interview I could give you useful
advice and if you were the student what
would you physics I absolutely agree
follow your passion but there are lots
of challenges so I'll throw out to one I
think was alluded to earlier which I
think it's such a big one
you know how do we feed a growing planet
we're going to have nine billion people
on this planet by 2015 that's 2 billion
more people that we have to figure out
how to feed and we've got changing
climate while we're at it which is going
to make it even harder so finding real
solutions to how whether it's new
sources of protein and we and we want to
be able to feed a growing planet while
also not increasing her carbon footprint
and while we're at it so that's one one
I'm working on right now is really quick
as just is also thinking about how do we
prepare for a global pandemic and and
how do we make sure we have the right
tools to respond bill gates will talk
about it as one of the greatest threats
alongside nuclear annihilation is that
you know a way that could wipe out human
species as we know it so so there's a
lot to be done on that area as well
thank you well I took very much agree
with David's s recommendation I would
interview but in more general terms
my advice is find something that you are
that you like that you're good at and
then do it with passion and then you're
going to probably be excellent at that
but just adding to that
if you're doing something and you
realize it benefits society it's even
more rewarding and if you are doing
something that you realize you are the
first one on this planet that you're
finding something new it's extremely
rewarding okay so I would just push you
find something interesting something you
really enjoy and do it with passion okay
so I'm gonna go back to the practical
again like with Wendy and you know lest
I sound like an advertising machine and
I actually quite seriously if you go to
Zooniverse org
there are did everybody get that there
are a hundred and twenty projects
ranging from astrophysics to cellular
biology with a whole bunch of ecology
projects many of them are run by
researchers at the University of
Minnesota you can take your pick of what
engages you going along with the you
know what is your passion you can try
different ones some of them you can only
you don't you don't actually have to
spend very much time with them to
actually contribute something so this is
sort of in this you know day and age
getting if you will a quick fix on
something this is a great way to feel
like you've contributed you know between
your homework sets or something like
that I don't know but furthermore it
gives you an opportunity to explore a
wide range of research areas to perhaps
help you hone in on what it is that you
actually really want to make your life's
passion I think your your advertising
works I think Dave is just gonzo our
hunter looks interesting oh yeah that's
mine so you turned out to be right that
seems to be the last question well it
was yours we really we have just a
minute left so let me just finish by
actually just asking one
question two the Nobel laureates here
you all addressed Grand Challenges in
your way is there anything that would
have made a big difference to the speed
with which you would have got to the
answer that would have that would fall
within the remit of how we should
approach Grand Challenges that was it
did the prize make a difference yeah did
the the the potential of being awarded a
prize at the end of it make it blind but
a difference no no no is there anything
that would have driven you to work far
haha well you know conceivably if so in
physics I'm a theorist trying to explain
a very fundamental facts that have been
revealed by experiments so if there'd
been more experiments a lot along the
path I followed would have made it
easier it's the only thing I can think
of anything well my own personal
experience somehow or other I became
fascinated with science in spite of
school my teachers were very boring and
furthermore some of things were actually
wrong I realized that later explaining
the seasons so well I would very much
encourage this education you can really
make children very enthusiastic about
science if you do it right okay they
work together and they do experiments
and they discuss them with each other
and so on it can be fascinating so I
would very much suggest that this would
be the large improvement for everybody
if you change the educational system
appropriately okay well let's stop there
that's wonderful thank you I think
there's been an enormous amount to take
away but I wouldn't like to try and
summarize it I think what I'd like to do
is to first of all give my own
advertisement for Mario Molina's talk on
climate change science and policy which
is going to be given here in this
lecture hall at 4 o'clock tomorrow so do
come along and otherwise I just like to
thank all the audience for being here
and for your wonderful questions I'm
sorry we couldn't take more and the
panel for a stimulating and wonderful
discussion thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]